Dude oh my god, is that Keanu Reeves?
Dude, that's Keanu Reeves
That's great. You need to get his autograph. No, I'm Way too embarrassed
I'm not gonna oh, come on, you'll be the one there's he's the nicest guy dude. Come on
Mr. Reeves
I'm gonna do for you guys
Keanu right. Um, is it cool if I maybe you get your autograph? Absolutely, I'd be honored. Yes
All right, thank you so much what's your name? I'm called Sam
Do we come on account of your focus back
Whoa back up chill, it's chill generous. I
Hate to intrude what looks like you're struggling
Look look whatever's in the register. I'll triple and then I'll match that to a charity of your choice
We'll do that absolutely I'd rather give
Are you
Guys point your guns at me instead. There's no way we can communicate effectively when you have guns pointed at each other's heads
Right now, let's just all take a deep breath together
I
Rode my bike here man. Okay. I know the cops
Listen, you can take my 1970 Ford Mustang from John wick. You can outrun the cops in it. I'll walk home and it's a win-win
Trust I can't believe how nice he is
Sir, just a car
You hear me look let me be your hostage
What the morning shit? Okay, Gianna mates just take the gonna put it to my head. What let him go Sammy go
Yes, and then you can put me in the audience. Don't what you do. It's okay. We'll make more money this what?
Sorry about that so Sam, right? Yeah
Do you still not want your car?
Fiamma thank you so much for taking time out of your busy schedule to give her out of us for one day
It was awesome. You guys are phenomenal your breath. Take your breath take. Yeah
Listen, I put together a very special playlist for everyone to check out of corridor film videos
You just have to make sure you subscribe and then hit the bell button to get all the notifications
For all the awesome videos to come. Alright guys, there's a link in the description to Kiana's playlist. Check it out
It's the best videos of ours that he liked. All right
Pleasure, it's been a real pleasure. Thank you